[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau 7,8
dossier pour ce numéro du strass et des
paillettes et du 8 au 19 mai dernier se
déroulait la 71e édition du festival de
cannes
et comme chaque année de nombreuses
yvelinois se sont rendus sur la
croisette pour la grande fête du cinéma
ils sont exploitants de salles
réalisateur étudiants ou même musicien
nous les avons rencontrés
le festival de cannes attire chaque
année douze mille professionnels du
cinéma ils sont réalisateurs producteurs
acteurs et même exploitant de salles par
mieux égale pineau le responsable du
grenier à sel de trappes vient depuis
une dizaine d'années sur la croisette
est l'occasion pour lui de faire des
rencontres et de voir des films beaucoup
de films trois à cinq projections par
jour est de dénicher quelques bonnes
idées
[Musique]
épi lo vous êtes présents ici à cannes
pour ce festival depuis le dimanche 6
mais dites moi à quoi ressemblent vos
journées sur place en a plusieurs types
de journée puisque les premiers jours
sont consacrés aux rencontres aux
réunions du réseau art et essai donc on
a beaucoup dernière assemblée générale
les réunions des avec toutes les
institutions
on voit beaucoup de films aussi ça c'est
les premiers jours et ensuite le
festival commence il a commencé cette
année le mardi soir s'est décalé par
rapport aux années précédentes
et là maintenant le festival c'est comme
chaque festivalier on essaie d'avoir le
plus de films possible donc on fait
beaucoup là que beaucoup beaucoup la
queue on mange quand on peut on marche
on traverse la ville dans tous les sens
l'intérêt ce but pour pour moi c'est
d'aller voir un maximum de films de
rencontrer aussi maximum de gens et on
est vraiment dans le monde entier et du
cinéma est réunie à cannes en ce moment
et c'est le moment pour rencontrer les
distributeurs les institutions les
collègues faire les réunions ça fait une
dizaine d'années que vous venez ici sur
place
en tant que passionné de cinéma de deux
responsables de salles comme le grenier
à sel de trappes pourquoi il faut être
ici pourquoi c'est le lieu où il faut
être
cannes c'est un endroit où il ya
beaucoup de décisions qui sont prises il
ya beaucoup d'annoncés qui sont faites
aussi par par le tas le cnc
les dracs et les distributeurs donc il
ya beaucoup de choses qui êtes si d'ici
qui s'annonce ici et c'est aussi le
moment pour rencontrer les collègues
connaître les problèmes des autres de
savoir quelle solution qu'ils ont
trouvée aux problèmes que l'on peut
avoir nous aussi
et aussi beaucoup voir les films parce
qu'en tant que programmateur
ça me permet de voir très en avance
certains films qui viendront
certainement certains très très
important pour pour l'année il ya un je
vous ai beaucoup vous avez vu beaucoup
de films
ici on va pas vous demander les coups de
coeur il faut il faut digérer tout ça
mais est-ce que ça va vous servir dans
la préparation de la programmation au
grenier à sel peut être des projections
qui seront proposés au grenier à sel
pour moi c'est arrivé dans le grenier à
sel attraper le programmation très art
et essai et tous les films du festival
sont son arrêt c'est donc donc
je fais mon choix dedans ça me permet de
les connaître à l'avance de pouvoir en
parler mieux aussi
et ça me permet de savoir de fermer
programme est
de la semaine de l'année et de
éventuellement d'anticiper vraiment s'il
ya une animation à faire s'il ya un coup
de coeur s'il ya une amie un quelqu'un a
que je peux essayer d'inviter et puis
mon pas se mentir il fait beau ça change
un petit peu de la région parisienne
donc on se ressource aussi pas mal
[Applaudissements]
le festival de cannes c'est le rendez
vous des hautes sphères du cinéma c'est
aussi pour un jeune réalisateur un lieu
idéal pour se développer
originaire de plaisir quentin dupieux en
est à son cinquième festival à la tête
d'une société de production et multiplia
cannes les rendez vous d'affaires
objectif financer ses projets
audiovisuels qui se chiffrent pour
certains à plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'euros
[Musique]
quentin depuis la dernière fois qu'on
vous avez suivi a quitté il ya deux ans
vous présentiez ici un court métrage au
chante film corner qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour vous depuis ses deux ans et
bad et puis ces deux ans j'ai monté ma
société de production belle 25
productions on s'occupe principalement à
deux axes principaux à de travailler une
partie publicité à la fois sur la france
et l'international notamment avec la
chine et une partie production de longs
métrages
là aussi aucune portée internationale et
multiculturelle
quand on gère une société de production
forcément au début d'un projet
audiovisuel il ya une question qui
revient c'est le financement comment ça
se passe quand on veut monter un projet
quand on veut monter un projet de
production de longs métrages en tout cas
c'est déjà beaucoup de temps et beaucoup
de patience et beaucoup de rencontres de
réseau
nous notre nous on amène des projets
donc c'est toujours le jeu c'est de
convaincre des investisseurs de venir
investir dans ce conte dans les films
qu'on a envie de développer de produire
donc tout le jeu de la production et là
c'est à dire d'aller voir le maximum de
gens de trouver des financements dans le
plus de pays possible suivant les
productions qu'on veut faire sur les
pays qu'on veut toucher les marchés
qu'on veut toucher et d'aller chercher
des investisseurs des financiers des
gens qui croient dans le projet pour les
emmener avec nous dans cette aventure
pour pour créer tout ça quand vous serez
à cannes jusqu'à la quasi fin du
festival jusqu'au 18 mai à quoi
ressemblent vos journées concrètement
depuis le début de ce festival bien
concrètement c'est beaucoup de
rendez-vous a principalement c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de rendez vous avec
voilà qu'on a préparé en amont des gens
qu'on rencontre aussi des soirées les
fameuses soirées cannoises où il ya
beaucoup de travail de networking et de
rencontre 6 et qui nous permet voilà
chaque jour d'avoir platine s'est
établie entre les rendez-vous les
déjeuners et les dîners et d'enchaîner
tout ça alors vous n'avez pas nous dire
qu'ils voulaient rencontrer mais ce que
des personnes sont intéressées par les
projets que vous présentez on a beaucoup
de chance cette année c'est un fait
celle qui se passe très bien pour nous
on a de l'intérêt notamment du côté de
la chine on a de l'intérêt aussi du côté
de l'angleterre et des états unis avec
des projets qu'on a notamment un projet
entre l'angleterre et la france donc ça
se passe plutôt très bien on est très
content avec mon associé le festival ces
rendez vous avec les boutons si le
financeur il déroule ici au sein du
palais du festival n'ont finalement très
très peu c'est plutôt dans les
restaurants dans les hôtels dans les
bars
le palais sert beaucoup pour la vente
des films ont souvent des hommes qui
sont déjà faits nous on est quand même
une étape de financement on est moins
formel vrai dans les rendez-vous les
lieux dans lesquels on se rend compte
avec avec les investisseurs et les
autres les coproducteurs dernière chose
c'est votre cinquième festival
il faut être ici à cannes surtout quand
on est à la tête d'une société de
production il faut il faut être présent
ici à cannes effectivement en tant que
ces deux productions c'est vraiment
important pour nous d'être présents à
cannes c'est le seul moment de l'année
des représentants dans tous les pays du
monde sont présents même lieu au même
endroit avec la même passion du cinéma
et pour développer des projets justement
là-dessus donc c'est très très important
pour nous et c'est une plate forme
incroyable
chaque année
[Applaudissements]
chaque année 80 mille festivaliers et
débarque à cannes pour la grande fête du
cinéma à côté des professionnels du
milieu ce sont ceux aussi en devenir des
étudiants à qui viennent pour la plupart
à leur premier festival et victoria
roblin et nicolas rodrigues à son de 3e
l'institut de l'image et du son à del en
cours ils ont inscrit leur court métrage
le temps d'un regard dans un espace
dédié le short film corner victoria
nicolas avant de parler du court métrage
le temps d'un regard pendant votre
présence ici à cannes pour des étudiants
en cinéma qui viennent de terminer leur
cursus qu'est le qu'est ce que ça
représente d'être ici pour vous alors
pour nous c'est très important d'être
ici parce que c'est parce qu on désire
rencontrer beaucoup de monde et de
rencontrer du monde
notamment pour faire parler un peu de
notre de notre court métrage et se faire
des nouvelles relations pour des projets
à venir se cultiver aussi un peu
lorsqu'il ya une énorme diversité de
films de jean donc voilà il ya plein de
films hyper intéressant à découvrir
qu'on n'aurait pas forcément l'occasion
de découvrir découvrir ailleurs et voilà
et participer aux soirées après pour
rencontrer des gens et discuter un peu
tout ça et quand on est dans le monde du
cinéma c'est le lieu où il faut être
cannes c'est important d'être ici
surtout pour nous disons que comme on
n'a pas de connaissances dans le cinéma
mine de rien cannes pendant quinze jours
c'est quand même une réunion de
professionnels ou même avec des rendez
vous pendant un an à paris on
on n'arriverait pas rencontré autant de
gens donc on va dans des soirées on
rencontre des professionnels
si on est au bon endroit au bon moment
qu'on a le bon scénario on peut avoir
une opportunité que ailleurs on n'aurait
pas alors vous avez inscrit six au short
film corner le court métrage le temps
d'un regard ça parle de quoi
le temps ailleurs alors le temps d'un
regard c'est une passion amoureuse
lilien en fait croiser son ex et le
temps d'un regard elle vit un souvenir
où elle ce soin de leurs moments forts
de la relation donc nous en fait on a
souhaité parler d'une passion amoureuse
parce que à part quelques films où j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment crédible comme un
vieux film je sais pas si vous
connaissez césar et rosalie voilà ou
même l'offre de gaspar noé je trouve que
leur passion amoureux sont crédibles à
l'écran et c'est ça que je trouve qu'il
manque un petit peu donc on a essayé de
faire la même chose avec un genre un peu
plus particulier voilà une dernière
question le temps d'un regard est
inscrit ici c'est un court métrage qui a
déjà été récompensé et qui est
sélectionné dans d'autres festivals
c'est ça alors depuis quelques mois on
l'inscrit à plusieurs festivals en
france et dans le monde entier
finalement il a été récompensé
le prix de la photographie au cinéma
tort donc un festival français et il a
été sélectionné au toronto film festival
est un film fait au los angeles film
festival aussi
villa schweppes plage du majestic ou
encore baoli la nuit cannoise bat son
plein pendant le festival de zibeline
ouaga vie polycarpe et vincent brunet
ont animé l'une de ses soirées à
l'atelier des merveilles éphémère le
chanteur m s'est également joint à la
partie jeunes et xavier et vincent ont
fréquenté le même lycée à la celle saint
cloud après leur carrière respective ils
se sont retrouvés et ont créé macadam
crocodile xavier et vincent vous
représentez donc le groupe macadam
crocodile vous produisez ce samedi 12
mai sur la terrasse du fei six hôtels
dans le cadre de la soirée des ateliers
des merveilles est éphémère parlez-nous
déjà de l'univers de macadam crocodile
qui allie style cet univers ben c'est un
univers qui est retranscrit par nos deux
faciès déjà annoncés tout part d'un
d'une une sorte de redire 2
deux collectifs qu'on a depuis longtemps
on a beaucoup de jamie ensemble depuis
des années et des années et des années a
eu plein de projets ensemble on vient là
on a fait de même lycée etc
et voilà l univers c'était c'est avant
tout le val a le plaisir le plaisir de
jouer et de se regarder dans les yeux
dessus un peu voilà ce que ça donne quoi
habituellement musicalement puisqu'elle
mme en c1
oui sa part donc d'une envie de jouer en
boucle de d'essayer de faire monter ce
qu'on peut dire une certaine trans dans
la musique apporte une certaine tranche
avec la répétition mais on va dire que
les opus no no no fin nos influences et
il ya de la funk de l'afro funk et
mélangé avec du disco du new disco
voilà il le truc plus moderne voilà un
peu trippant quand on peut dire aussi
qu'ils permettent de voir deux des
longues montées des longues envolées et
c'est uniquement aussi des performances
en live c'est ça jusqu alors c'est qu'on
a fait ou n'a rien à voir juste créée en
fait on n'a rien enregistré c'est que du
live et on voit là on a fait beaucoup de
concerts donc on se demande peut être si
on n'a pas enregistré et le fait d'être
présent ici à cannes pendant le festival
est ce que c'est un choix de votre part
peut-être vous passionnés de cinéma où
ça s'est fait tout à fait par hasard
cette programmation est le fait de jouer
ici ce soir c'est une très grosse
opportunité c'est une très grosse
opportunité pour pour cannes de nous
avoir en ce samedi 12 mais c'est vrai
enfin en fait le festival s'est
construit autour de nous ça veut dire
que cette année on voulait faire du
macadam crocodile avant tout on s'est
dit qu'est ce qu'on peut faire un
peut-être qu'on peut faire un festival
de cinéma et c'est effectivement on aime
bien le cinéma
certaines données non et d'aucune piste
heureusement c'est là c'est loïc a donc
qui s'occupe de l'âme il sait qu'il est
à dire que c'est dans un endroit où on
joue ce soir qui nous a contactés il ya
des amis ou
ils ont proposé de venir pour festival
depuis un an et demi avec toute une
bande de musiciens kong avec qui on est
amis on habite de jouer un peu ensemble
et matthieu chedid qui étaient là aussi
donc c'est super on a fait un super
jamie hier de deux heures et qu'est-ce
que vous avez concocté à ce soir pour
personnes qui vont assister à cette
performance de la sphère et j'espère de
l' envie de danser parce que notre but
c'est que voilà les gens dansaient doit
faire plaisir et de faire plaisir vous
faire danser les gens ont vraiment dans
ce truc là de faire partie de la de
faire partie de la fête quoi oued 1
jusqu'à qu'un show à proprement parler
quoi c'est la fin de ce set 8 dossier
spécial cannes merci de l'avoir suivi le
mois prochain vous avez rendez vous avec
nicolas landry pour un numéro consacré à
la coupe du monde de football à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]